meine damen und herren ich weiß es ist
für uns alle die sechste stunde aber
eine richtig gute nachricht habe ich
noch unsere grundschule in deutschland
wird 100 jahre alt
100 jahre und genauso sehen die meisten
grundschulen auch leider aus 100 jahre
grundschule da werden sicher viele zdf
zuschauer zu hause ganz nostalgisch weil
die ganzen schönen bilder aus der
kindheit wieder hoch kommen die ganzen
erinnerungen an die gute alte schwarze
pädagogik ja wie sich die zeiten ändern
heute werden nur noch die lehrer gehauen
jetzt die schlechte nachrichten
jetzt die schlechte nachricht der
lehrermangel wird langsam echt
dramatisch
aktuell arbeiten an dieser grundschule
in niemberg in sachsen anhalt nur drei
vollzeit lehrer zuständig für vier
klassen mit insgesamt 105 schüler drei
lehrer für vier klassen so wahnsinnig
schlecht in mathe ist das gut nein
ja wir sind jetzt ernsthaft an dem punkt
meine damen und herren ohne sogenannte
quereinsteiger würde unser komplettes
schulsystem morgen zusammenbrechen wenn
man glück hat wenn man großes glück hat
erwischt man noch einen mit ja
pädagogischen vorkenntnissen
allerdings mangelt es wären dann
vielleicht an anderer stelle in dieser
klasse habe ich ein halbes jahr englisch
unterricht gegeben obwohl ich gar kein
englisch kranke roger faxon
obwohl ich kein englisch kann das gibt
es doch gar nicht doch gleich günther
oettinger das kann ja allen dingen der
war ja und wenn man darüber nachdenkt
ist es überhaupt nicht mehr lustig denn
lehrermangel trifft leider besonders
schulen in sogenannten brennpunkt
viertel so nennt man die brennpunkt
vierteln weil weil jungen lehrer was ja
auch völlig okay ist sich ihre schulen
in der praxis meistens aussuchen können
das heißt aber gerade kinder die
eigentlich mehr förderung bräuchten
fallen jetzt noch tiefer durch den rost
in berlin zum beispiel da gelten an
manchen brennpunktschulen schon die
quereinsteiger als elite in berlin haben
wir die besondere situation dass selbst
die quereinsteiger nicht mehr
ausreichend quereinsteiger waren die die
wenigstens einfach der berliner schule
studiert haben jetzt haben wir so
genannte local da sind die lehrkräfte
ohne volle lehrbefähigung die haben
manchmal irgendwas studiert löffel
beziehungsweise rofl ja bald reicht es
wahrscheinlich wenn man mal eine tüte
studentenfutter gegessen hat das
schlimme ist wir lachen aber das
schlimme ist genau so fördert man
ungleichheit denn auch die zahl der
privatschulen wächst bei uns ständig
seit 1993 um 81% privatschule schicken
so liberale öko eltern ihre kinder gerne
hin weil man da doch mehr unter sich
bleibt wenn sie verstehen was ich meine
ja
doch strich kanada deswegen deswegen
wenn ich da gar nicht aus deswegen geht
der kleine merlin tiberius aus
christliche gymnasium oder gleich zur
waldorfschule denn da sind noch weniger
ausländer weil man den namen gekannt so
schlecht tanzen kann
jetzt hat die bertelsmann stiftung auch
noch errechnet
uns fehlen bis 2025 bundesweit 11.000
grundschullehrer mehr als von der
kultusministerkonferenz ursprünglich
vorhergesagt immer wie können die denn
immer wieder so derartig daneben liegen
niemand spricht kann darüber aber in
deutschland können 17 von 16
kultusminister nicht richtig rechnen
duda bis frage wenn ein kind 2009/10
geboren wird wann wird es eingeschult
kultus wenn es da wenn diese leute einen
schulabschluss haben dann schafft es
wirklich jeder sie sahen eine
information der stiftung politiker mit
dyskalkulie werden neben quereinsteigern
werden gerade auch immer mehr
pensionierte lehrer zurückgeholt das
passiert regelmäßig oder hier fällt mir
gerade einfach ist er mit bernd höcker
ja warum wir nicht warum denn durch
extrem qualifiziert er ist gelernter
geschichtslehrer ich sage ihnen wenn der
band in den schuldienst zurückkehren
dann dann haben wir ein festes probleme
und dann wird das entsprechende
konsequenzen haben ich kann ihnen sagen
dass sie gekommen zu künsten hat droht
der kommende reichskanzler
wir kommen vom thema wir kommen vom
thema ab ich behaupte wir haben gar
nicht zu wenig lehrer pro klassenzimmer
unsere klassenzimmer sind einfach zu
klein
ja da gehen höchstens weil sie nicht 30
40 plagen rein für den unterricht von
morgen musst du wie der kollege mario
barth in die großen hallen gehen
langsam
erdkunde bei frau lösen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die deutschen mitbürger habt ihr kaufen
stadiontour der kunde bei frauen diesen
coup stettler
ja
ganz andere atmosphäre vorprogramm ist
übrigens latein mit bushido in unserer
schönen hauptstadt hatte zu beginn des
schuljahres nur noch kein witz ein
achtel der neueingestellten
grundschullehrer einen uni-abschluss
fürs lehramt nur noch ein achtes berlin
war hier neues youtube tutorial vom
berliner senat
du bist volljährig hast nix zu tun aber
tierisch bock dein leben endgültig weg
zu werfen dann herzlich willkommen zum
tutorial lehrer in unter zwei minuten
stell dich unserem aufwendigen
quereinsteiger auswahlverfahren wir
wollen nur die besten der besten
haben sie schon mal mit kindern
gearbeitet nein
neben loch holz und quereinsteigern
unterrichten in berlin übrigens auch
noch sogenannte quereinsteiger aber das
ist natürlich andere geschichte vor dem
unterricht an der brennpunktschule noch
schnell den organspendeausweis ausfüllen
und los geht's
mein name klempnow versucht die ersten
momente im job zu überstehen ohne plan
natürlich ohne hilfe von sonderpädagogen
wie man echt bräuchte weil dir auch mit
förder intensiven adhs schülern zu tun
hast und das alles bei einem lärmpegel
von circa 5000 dezibel
am ende des ersten arbeitstages meldest
du deswegen burnout für die nächsten 30
jahre krank berliner grundschullehrer in
unter zwei minuten und nächste woche
wird als quereinsteiger gehirn zurück in
der berliner charité
martin köster
ja
laut potsdamer lehrerstudie liegt die
burn out quote bei lehrern bei 29
prozent von allen berufen die höchste
zusammen mit erzieherin lehrermangel ich
sage da sind endlich kreative lösungen
gefragt einfach mal quer denken sowie
friedemann weise ratschläge in die
fresse mit friedemann weise schon wieder
lehrermangel
zwischendurch hatte man ja mal gehofft
dass durch die [__] you goethe filme
wieder mehr kinder den wunsch entwickeln
lehrer zu werden
leider haben die meisten nur den wunsch
entwickelt elias m'barek zu heiraten ich
auch frontalunterricht passt sowieso
nicht mehr in unsere zeit bildung muss
da passieren wo die jugendlichen gerne
sind im club zum beispiel wenn der
türsteher einfach 23 französische
vokabeln abfragen was für'n arsch bist
du denn und im club schreibt er diese
dann nicht mehr nur ich will eure hände
sehen sondern auch noch und wie viele
sind das geteilt durch 4 x 3
wir müssen die kinder am besten da
abholen wo sie sowieso sind also im
internet youtube
das sind die neuen lehrer hier deutsch
bei julia und joey
was war das deutsche korrektes deutsch
war das seien party zu präsent von seien
und bei denen lernt man auch physik auf
den tisch dann holt runter landes am
boden ganz genau julia wenn was
runterfällt liegt auf dem boden
schöner hätte sagt newton auch nicht
sagen können kommt noch mehr
naturwissenschaften additive
farbmischung in drei sekunden erklärt er
hat kunde unterrichten youtuber auch
hier geht es darum was wäre wenn
frankreich und england ein land werden
fragen sie mich nicht warum überlegt
euch einfach mal was das für ein
heftiges land wäre also das hier ist ja
frankreich also kennt ja jeder und das
ist ja das vereinte königreich und die
beiden zusammen dass er einfach das
heftigste land in europa in europa wie
wir deutschen wollten die auch mal zu
einem land machen aber die wollten
vergesst den lehrermangel youtube das
ist zeitgemäßer unterricht hier lernen
1,5 millionen abonnenten endlich wie man
eine mango schneidet das messer bringen
wir jetzt nur am anfang und zwar um
diese familie zu halbieren
es ist so hatte brannte es im kern wenn
ich lüge nicht wenn ich jetzt sage das
war es anstrengend was ich finde dass in
zehn jahren gemacht sagt man nicht über
namen mango scanner bin ich erst gemerkt
besteuert und das liebe kinder war eine
rhetorische frage so aufgabe bis morgen
schreibt mir hier jeder seine
kreditkartennummer unten in die
kommentare
prüfnummer nicht vergessen